>> Can India become a superpower?
Well, of course it can.
The question is will it and how quickly?
Without getting into all the details I think
there are many reasons why
several experts believe that India will become
an affluent nation
within one generation.
And -- and all of that, as an Indian that
I read, and excited about
what I read, and deeply will that to happen,
there are 2 or 3
challenges that India would face if it were
to face it were to become a
superpower.
First is finding a model which will drive
inclusive growth without
which the shining India story and India becoming
a superpower which we
talk about is unlikely to have a fairytale
ending because there will be
far too many people who will -- who will not
be part of this wonderful
economic growth story that we're talking about.
So to me, India can become a superpower provided
it embraces the
criticality of developing a model which will
drive inclusive growth and
which will get a billion-plus people fully
integrated into the growth
story that we have.